[Music]
right up top this is what I'm wearing is
my outfit for the show jacket jagad tie
shoes tasteful ladies song
just kidding it's not tasteful here's
what I'm wearing this I'm dressed up why
why am I dressed up because I'm on TV
and I have to do you understand I don't
want to wear any of these things I just
want to look nice for the shop really
hoping to the show tonight hope he likes
thongs you know what I like to be
wearing I'd like to be wearing no pants
no shirt no shoes just boxers loose
bathrobe barely time I believe they call
it the Lebowski that's my Lebowski it
just sounds it's not working
I'm not gonna stop
I love bathrobes bathrobes it's a robe
who's the who put the word bath
in front of the word row like that's the
only place you're allowed to wear it do
I say it's an all the time robe and it's
been done before you know who rocked in
all the time robe kings go to a museum
any time you see a painting of like an
old-timey king they're wearing bathrobes
big Red King bathrobes with that white
soft leopard trim why cuz they're the
king that's like their first decree
they're like right off the bat I shall
be robed in the finest Cotton's
from the realm of Brookstone it's right
next to the Apple store which is right
next to the pear store
[Music]
because back then they didn't have
computers ads well we have to get
dressed up I want to talk about that why
do you have to get dressed up friends
and sex that's why you get dolled up
that's all it is to get sex and make
friends or hopefully make sex with
friends or if you're lucky sex with a
cast member of friends
looking at you leblanc hope you like
thongs Joey well what I'm really saying
here is that no one wants to wear
uncomfortable clothes we just put them
on to make a good image that's why we're
things like those jackets jackets huge
queue jacket
uncomfortable hot heavy it's not cold in
here this is just a double thick shirt
I'm wearing over my single thick shirt
like a real but we wear them
because they're expensive so they it's
like social advertising it sends out a
message you see a guy in a jacket like
this you're like oh that guy probably
has a job which means he probably has a
house which means he probably has snacks
that's all I'm thinking I see you in
this jacket I'm thinking gushers and
Chex Mix that's it that's Hatem
oppressive waist noose exterior Spanx
giving our hips the worst hug but you
got to wear a belt as if to say flex I
won't be embarrassing you at major
social functions just like sorry for
your loss
it's hard to whistle while you're
laughing or I'd keep doing it
your grandma's over there like I told
you to find a nice boy with a belt I say
let's live like the rogue kings I think
everybody should be walking around with
bedhead that's honest
holes in the armpit of your favorite
t-shirt with the neck hole all stretched
out just go to work like that your boss
be like I love the frayed boxers you
wore during the presentation today
Sanderson Fruit of the Loom is for
closers skinny jeans too they're out no
more skinny jeans these are skinny jeans
I'm 35
I say loose but jeans that's the last
time you rocked a pair of loose but it's
a dream a dream we didn't have to wake
up from
I want loose butt all the time so loose
in the butt when you go back for your
wallet you have room to make an entire
fist and still grab the wallet loose
flip-flops to let him breathe that's
what I say flip-flops are great they're
not just for college freshmen clapping
they're way over there disgusting fungus
filled shower blasts Kylie used this
Moss man
some people are anti flip-flop they say
your feet are gross and that they smell
ya when you wrap them in thick cotton
socks and suffocate them all day inside
a pair of leather Pumas let him out let
him breathe and reclaim the glory they
deserve as our downstairs hands
I spend entire weekend just wearing a
sheet I never lie in the monologue I've
worn a sheep I woke up in the sheet
shuffled to the bathroom and went wait a
minute this doesn't have to end
I wore a bed sheet you can too
if you want to get fancy white top sheet
underneath blue over sheet here I say
good enough for Jesus good enough for
yep the King of Kings rocked a bed sheet
look what he did he didn't dress to
impress yeah that's probably why the
Lord was so chilling spreading love and
good vibes he was comfortable we put the
Lord and some loose but jeans who knew
would happen
[Applause]
[Music]